good morning thank you for coming this
if you haven't seen any of my talks
before I have tend to have graffiti or
street all right on my slides and I will
today as well but this is kind of
special to me because this is from özil
so this is down by the harbor so it's a
it's quite beautiful I think so welcome
to secure programming practices in C++ I
did this talk once before at a security
conference and then they all had fun
titles but since we're not at a security
conference you don't get a fun title C
you get the boring one my name is
Patricia oz I'm a programmer I work on
the Vivaldi browser I used to work a
long time ago on the Opera browser and
in between I was a consultant a little
bit and I worked at Cisco making
telepresence systems so there are two
quotes from viana sea makes it easy to
shoot yourself in the foot c++ makes it
harder but when you do it blows your
whole leg off but actually my favorite
is the next one within C++ there is a
much smaller and cleaner language
struggling to get out and that is the
part that most people miss about C++ and
in the end we'll get there but before
that we'll have fun so this is the
agenda for today and I'll you'll see it
several times then you'll see the
underlined this thing move down so you
know where you are but first we're look
at what kind of specs exists then we'll
look a little bit at undefined behavior
a little bit at the surprising compiler
optimizations then we'll look at
exploitability and that will be like a
large chunk of the talk and then take
your vitamins and then the eight I'd
really rather you didn't which are my
opinions okay so what kind of specs
exists and that was a major part of
researching for this talk I wanted to
see what kinds of things you could
actually look at and there are quite a
few but I chose three and the first one
that is still
not sufficiently famous is the C++ core
guidelines so are you familiar with the
C++ core guidelines yeah little bit
basically it's a collaborative effort
led by Brianna and trying to distill
more what we think or they think of as
best practices in C++ and it is very
very instructive very so I would I would
recommend browsing around a little bit
but it is quite big like if we go back
it's if you try to print it it's quite
large 328 pages but still that's quite
small considering if we come to the say
search C++ coding standard which is only
for C++ you have one for C as well which
you kind of have to add on and then
you're going close to a thousand pages
but the say cert C and C++ coding
standard is a software coding standard
for the C and C++ programming languages
developed by the search coordinate
Coordination Center to improve the
safety reliability and security of
software systems but basically it's it's
going through different kinds of
problems that you might get in an ad
advice on how to get out but this is the
one that I'm going to look at the most
today it's the common weakness
enumeration now this is massive but
basically it describes patterns in code
that make vulnerabilities so we're going
to look at a bunch of those yeah so it
is a category system I think it was
mostly meant in the beginning to to help
automated tools but it is also very
instructive to look at it it's text and
so if you find yourself on one of them
then read through and it has good advice
okay so undefined behavior I talked I
talked to some C++ programmers yesterday
because I find it kind of funny because
this is sort of like what we would think
is as the most painful part of C++ but
for some reason C++ programmers love to
talk about and
I think we're kind of masochistic this
like the war the worse it is the better
really but for most people they might
not know what undefined behavior is
which is one of the interesting parts of
C and C++ so I'll read this and this is
from from the spec so it says examples
of undefined behavior are memory
accesses outside of array bounds signed
integer overflow null pointer
dereference modification of the same
scale or more than once in an expression
without sequence points access to an
objects through a pointer of a different
type etc and this is and this part is
like the the fun part compilers are not
required to diagnosed a undefined
behavior although mainly simple
situations are diagnosed and the
compiled program is not required to do
anything meaningful and we'll see how
easy it is to make undefined behavior
very soon and we'll have one fun right
now so after this slide so but the basic
advice I would say about an undefined
behaviour don't try to reason about it
most programmers have this tendency to
want to reason about it they'll be like
yeah but blah blah blah and there's like
don't because it's getting not only has
it always been difficult to reason but
with more and more advanced optimizing
compilers it is getting more and more
impossible to reason about it
so just assume it crashes or it's never
executed don't try to manipulate and
depend on undefined behavior because
when you if you do and you probably do
most people do when you change your
compiler or you compile the version or
your optimization level suddenly you
will break your application and that's
usually how you find out you're
depending on on the front behavior and
this is an example and it is inspired by
Shafiq young Moore on Twitter his
Twitter handle is down there I if you if
you find undefined behavior to be a fun
thing he he has a lot of fun too
it's an undefined behavior just follow
him on Twitter he's a lot of fun there
and this is from Stack Overflow where
he's also very active in C++ and but
basically this loop has this Delta
access here this access outside of our
bounds which is undefined behavior if
you run this program it is an infinite
loop it is supposed to go for iterations
it runs forever because undefined
behavior doesn't will introduce programs
where you end up maybe not doing
anything meaningful because the compiler
can do optimizations based on the fact
that this doesn't have to happen but
that leads us into the next one which is
compiler optimizations because this is a
common this was a compiler optimization
based on something that was undefined
behavior but you can get surprising
effects even if it there is no undefined
behavior so I'm going to give an example
and in fact or of a compiler after my
station crossing surprising effect this
was a very n is still a very famous
vulnerability that that hit a lot of
applications and that is the case of the
disappearing memset and it deals around
code like this so basically you have
[Music]
some function that needs other user to
login so then you get the password from
the user then you do your operation when
you're done with your operation you you
have this this password in memory and
you don't like to keep it around in
memory so now you want to zero out this
part of memory and this is looks
perfectly reasonable except that the mem
set is removed by the optimizer because
the optimizer views this as a dead store
no one is ever going to read this memory
again
there's no reason to write this this was
a very surprising thing that happened to
quite a lot of products that ended up
having credentials in memory that they
thought they had taken away so yesterday
I went to a bunch of C++ talks and I
realized that the dumb thing if I want
to be cool is that I should probably
show you this uncaught bolts so I never
do live demo so this will be as live as
you're gonna get
ever so let's see okay so is that I'm
not going to try to make it bigger so
that's unfortunate if it's not big
enough because I'll probably mess it up
but if you go and look down here
that's a mem set so that's good but we
have no optimisation so let's go -
there's still some code here but the
website is already gone let's just
there is no memset any optimization
level it's gone
so it might look good in debug and then
in release your password is still there
okay let's see it'll come back okay so
if you see on the bottom here I have I
have some references to different kinds
of parts of other so here the era of the
sae which says has two sections which is
related to this one is be aware of
compiler optimizations which we have
talked about and you should now be aware
and the other one is clear sensitive
information stored in reusable resources
and how to do that but there has been
some solutions around this for people
who are used to Windows I assume this
secure zero memory might be familiar on
Linux this memset underscore s has
implemented some places but I don't
think it is on Ubuntu at least and so if
you have code like this in your
application and go and read these pages
they have workarounds for different
kinds of compilers and different kinds
of platforms but this is not a solved
problem so if you if you have things
like this then have a look ok so now
we've looked a little bit at those but
it's more fun to look at code so let's
look at exploitability we're going to go
through these ten unsigned integer
wraparound sign integer overflow numeric
truncation stack buffer overflow heat
buffer overflow but for underflow used
after free double free incorrect type
conversion and uncontrolled string
format and the thing is one of the
things that I find interesting as being
super stressed program above being
interested in security is that a lot of
the things that security researchers
consider vulnerabilities C++
developers consider bugs because it is
generally the program is not behaving as
it's supposed to what makes it a
vulnerabilities if you can use that
behavior to do something else so I wrote
the code I put it on github and yeah
well it's on my github so we you can
look at it there I got some complaints
that these some of my examples weren't
really fair to see which is probably
true because I'm going to concatenate
two buffers like they were strings but I
don't really care about about null
terminating the strings and things but
you have to fit things on the slide and
on the other hand you probably wouldn't
concatenate strings like this is C
either but I'm trying to prove a point
so so we'll do sign integer wraparound
and sine integer overflow and American
Cajun at first now there's quite a bit
of code here but the code is going to be
repeated so we'll take it over slow the
first time and that'll be easier so
basically you have three lengths first
length second length and buf length
first length is you and max so this is
an unsigned int and all of them are in
sign-ins and we're going to make buffers
of these sizes and the other ones are
256 because I like that number and but
anyway so we want to check before we
copy into buff we want to check the buff
is it has sufficiently size to fit boast
first and second so we add first to
second to check that is under 256 of
course now you see that it's not but I
had to fit on the slide so assume it
came as a parameter but if you add first
to second because of and this is this is
defined behavior this is not undefined
behavior unsigned integer wraps and when
you add 256 to you and max it big the
answer is 255 which is clearly under 256
so we go in and we do the copy this is
this is very
often what you will see like this isn't
I'll show you another example is well
I'll point to it in another example with
Malik where you have the same kind of
idea but the point here is that you are
trying to bypass checks in the code by
by wrapping or overflowing integers or
unsigned integers so let's look at a
sign integer overflow now this is
undefined behavior so other things could
also happen but in this case we're going
to go at what happened on my machine
right so here we have first length is
now in int Max and second and buff is
the same we do exactly the same again
now we add first length the second
length this will this will overflow what
happens now is undefined behavior but
and all of the like all the times I've
tested this number is negative which is
clearly under 256 and we go in and we
copy right ok so then we have no numeric
truncation error now this is really easy
to do so look at that so first length
now is you and Max minus 256 so we know
if you add 256 to it will still be fine
and then we make our buffers again but
now we pull the check for the new length
into another variable and we are going
to put it into an int now unfortunately
int does not have room for you in max
and that's unfortunate because this is
again this is not undefined behavior
this is implementation dependent
behavior which is a whole other category
of things but it doesn't really matter
in our case because this number turns
out to be negative of my machine which
is less than 256 and we go in again okay
so those were the fun numbers and
basically all of the vulnerabilities
around this are around things like that
you make a number of really big so you
can make it really small and pass checks
okay so then we're gonna look at
overflows now generally you you might
start with the with some kind
have signed or unsigned int overflow
wraparound thing and generally end up in
something that is a stack stack where
heat based overflow because what you
often want to do is you want to write
things that you want to do stuff with in
this vulnerability so now you need to
write it somewhere so this is this is
quite a boring one in a way but it is
illustrate something that has been a
traditionally very common vulnerability
and this is basically just reading
random stuff in not really knowing how
big it is and writing it into your own
memory now this is actually to cwe so if
you see that it's called cwe to now 121
which is stack based of buffer overflow
but if you look over gets it got its own
number so so 242 inherently dangerous
function I had to jump through some
hoops to be able to get this code to
compile even so this is a good thing see
you shouldn't be using it but anyway so
here you have a stack stack allocated
buffer and then your reading random
stuff to it that can be much bigger and
then possibly overriding your stack and
this one is interesting in two ways will
do the the first one let's see so you
have the heat based a buffer overflow so
now you're going to allocate on the heap
and then you're gonna copy something
that is bigger than what it fits and
then you are going to write outside of
your buffer on the heap instead but what
you will see here also you have the
malloc and you said sizeof cart times
ten this is a very typical scenario on
where you would also use the integer
overflow so instead of the ten you will
have some kind of integer and you will
get it to wrap and so the the code that
is writing thinks that there is
sufficient space but you made the actual
actual allocation small so that's
another typical scenario
those yeah then we go to the next one
buffer underwrite underflow and this is
basically going the other way so instead
of writing off the end you're going to
write off the beginning so basically
going the other direction and so it's
not very interesting but it's the same
idea so you get you you have some kind
of bug in your loop and then that makes
you be able to to write all the way so
if you can manipulate the input in a
good way and that this is this is often
how you do it because you have to get
your stuff in somehow right so generally
you will manipulate some kind of input
that that the code gets you first
analyze the code try to figure out what
kind of vulnerabilities it is then you
massage a little bit the input to get it
in a certain way to get the code to
behave like you want so that is numbers
and that is strings that might be files
or media files or protocols where you
can manipulate header parameters to
basically make the code do what you want
okay and these are these are typical
like c++ bugs right but but they can
also be misused but they but how you
will generally see these things
happening is you won't generally see
them in regular use because you will
generally get bugs and generally you use
if you if you have these kinds of things
so here you have a use after free this
will generally cause crashes so you
would have seen it most likely so where
you see these actually turning up is
usually where the the buffer is only
freed in an error situation so if you
can manipulate the program to come into
an error condition when suddenly it will
do the free and then later use it now
you you have memory in a bad state you
have undefined behavior you can maybe
use other things to end manipulate it so
this is and this is the same thing with
way to say you say here you have the use
after free and then you have the double
free and the double fee is usually
introduced in the same way you
you only freed it on an error and then
later you do some kind of memory
analyzer saying oh no this buffer leaked
and then somebody put in another delete
it's it's an easy thing to happen right
yeah so incorrect type conversion this
is uh this is one of my favorite things
you can't do this in other languages I
like the fact that in the C and C++ if
you really really want to you can cast
an apple to a pear and the compiler will
say yeah I I believe you you know what
you're doing so here we have to clearly
unrelated things and yeah sure if you do
a hard C cast you can cast an A to B you
can do that it's a feature
language okay and the good thing okay
the one thing that you can do with this
is let's say that you had some memory
that was allocated for something else
but now you managed to take it over
somehow maybe using it after free or
something now you can just make an
object there of your own choosing or you
can make a manipulated class to
manipulate the fields of an existing
object with your new pointer with new
features there's lots of things that you
can do that will make this useful and
this is this is the the programming
world's version of sequel injection
right you're basically getting some kind
of external format string and then you
just trusting your input and you're just
letting it go so in this case you're
getting your format through your
command-line argument you're getting
your strings through your command-line
argument that new calling printf this is
not a very good program but you but you
could and now you can just do a
percentage that's fine it will put the
string in and then you could do a
percent D and it will just print around
the memory now a good thing about things
like this is that you can actually get
like valid memory addresses and things
like that that you can actually get
print out you can get information out of
the program if you're able to do this
something that you can use to maybe
used to - maybe attack it in a different
way so you can get pointer addresses and
things like that okay so we looked at a
whole like a little chunk of
exploitability and this is the take your
vitamins part so use your tools there
are quite a lot of tools because most
most likely you will have some all many
vulnerabilities in your code and a good
way of finding them is using the tools
that you have and and like I said before
if you're looking for things like
undefined behavior then changing your
compiler using many different compilers
using many different optimization levels
and then running through your test
Suites that's a good way of figuring out
that you are depending on undefined
behavior but also taking care to look at
your errors and warnings do
instrumentation fuzzing static analysis
all of the things that are are available
to try to find these things and fix them
then you have paid products to to do do
static analysis but many times you'll
have to do dynamic analysis okay so then
we come to my my part my opinions okay
so this is my the eight I'd really
rather you didn't and they are inspired
by the eight condiments of festive
arianism which is great and you should
go read them on Wikipedia but these are
mine so don't take me too seriously
but seriously think about it so these
are the ones I'd really rather you
didn't you see I'd really rather you
didn't allocate with new I'd really
rather you didn't do math a lot and
really rather you didn't trust your
external input I'd really rather you
didn't use pointers a lot I'd really
rather you didn't write clever code I'd
really rather you didn't use shared
pointer a lot and I'd really rather you
didn't share state a lot now the first
four we'll go through a little bit more
and the last four not so much
I'd really rather you didn't you see and
here I can point to the core guidelines
right the core guidelines has a point on
this prefer C++ to see because C++ has
very good features that will make it so
you don't have to use many of the
dangerous features of C so try to use
C++ language and the facilities that are
there to avoid many of these situations
and in this case this is how you
concatenate two strings and C++ don't go
trying to copy and make buffers and move
things around and use car stars and just
try to avoid it as much as possible and
especially if you're going to manipulate
it use STD string or your own company
string but be safe about it and also
many people don't know that you can do
this in C++ because they learn C++ in
the 90s right and they're like I don't
really know how you do this okay it is
perfectly normal
we can do a perfectly normal
concatenation with plus and C++ and if
you want to read in from standard in or
out you do it with STD scene or SVC out
and you will have things that are
properly sized so don't don't try to be
fancy just do it the normal way yeah and
this is the this is the one that was
buffer under flow before but instead of
making a fancy loop because basically
try to avoid loops in C++ just don't do
that any kind of loop tried to do
algorithms try to do do program like
beer inside and this is this is split up
just because it rendered better on the
slime but here you have a lambda it's
called is : and you pass it in to find
if to find the
one it searches from the end and then if
it when when it finds one which is like
in the middle of hello in world it will
erase everything from there until the
end and that was what the other code was
doing but it was kind of hard to tell so
this is more readable as well and less
prone to error and then if you want to
cast we have casts this is how we've
been casting since early 2000 so this is
the way to go and these are save casts
so in this case we have a Spider Man and
Iron Man and everybody knows that
aspiring my spider-man is not an Iron
Man and so we make a Spider Man we call
him Peter and then we want to set a Tony
pointer to Peter but Tony is an Iron Man
pointer and it's clear that you cannot
have an Iron Man pointer pointing to
spider-man and you can't and Klein says
you can't with the little mice errors
just in like arrows that pinpoints
exactly where it is and says error
static cast from spider-man pointer to
Iron Man pointer which are not related
by inheritance is not allowed so you're
going to get compiled time errors for
forecasts I'd really rather you didn't
allocate with knew now this is very
difficult from people coming from other
kinds of languages like like Java for
example to C++ because they're used to
always allocating with new and I'm
coming through the point where I think
you should practically never allocate
with new you have to have a really good
reason to allocate with new and that's
kind of strange for people so I would
say I would prefer if you allocate on
the stack that is like my first
preference if you can allocate on the
stack it's nice it will manage your
scope um so here we have a stack here oh
he where he lives on the stack he's very
happy there and his scope will be
controlled by the lifetime of where he
is or his lifetime will be I'll be
controlled by the scope he's in which is
good if you have to have something
on the heath they use unique pointer um
and here you can say that you can create
something on the heap by calling make
unique so there's no new there either so
this is the good thing is you can make
code so that you can actually grep
through your code for new so this is an
alternative to the one underneath we're
using new to allocate a hero but the
good thing here is now you have a unique
pointer on the stack which will manage
the lifetime of your hero on the heap
and it will delete it when it goes out
of scope it is well behaved toward with
regards to moves and so use unique
pointer if you have to have something on
the heap because even though we don't
have a garbage collection some people
like to pretend that we have a garbage
collection and they call it stack based
scope a garbage collection so basically
you end up with the garbage collection
happens at the curly bracket it's very
nice you don't have to run around take
deleting your own memory which also
means you won't delete it twice if you
you you take the handle down with the
memory you also know that you're not
accessing the handle after the memory is
gone yeah so deterministic garbage
collection we like to call that and then
we have something called make sure and I
have a separate point on I really rather
you didn't use make sure but if you have
to then this is how you do it
you can hold a pointer our shared
pointer from the from the stack we're
transitively from the stack so you have
something on the stack that owns
something that owns something that you
know but you can also do that with make
sure so it's still no new here ok and
this I'd really rather you didn't do
math a lot now this is because you saw
earlier we had all of these stack you
know these overflows integer overflow
and wraparound and these things and
basically my opinion is that primitive
types have no semantics and what I mean
by that is that an
doesn't mean anything and int is a
storage form but it does hot doesn't
have any meaning you can't say that
somebody's age is an int because it
doesn't make sense an int can be
negative an int can be huge it doesn't
make sense it has no semantics but it
does have actual physical limits which
gives it a lot of problems so I would
say try to reduce the value space if you
can if you're using it for something
that has semantics then give it
semantics and there are facilities in
the language to give it cement is give
it some kind of meaning so I wouldn't
use enum
anymore it has its own set of
vulnerabilities so don't do that but an
enum class we have now in C++ string
literals can be very useful used to
define literals are kind of cool and
especially when they're especially when
you can make unicorns with them I don't
have an example of that way you can look
you know somebody had an example of that
and then spice tea iced tea I I think I
like okay so let's look at an enum class
and why it's cool so here we have an
enum class on top it's called direction
it has north east west west and south
now the one of the major features with
regards to security of an enum class it
has no automatic conversion to end so
there's no way to compare to enums that
are different in ohms but have the same
value connected to them so if here I've
actually assigned them to card just to
show you that you can but let's say that
they were 1 2 3 & 4 if you had another
enum that also was 1 2 3 & 4 they would
not be equal and that is that is one of
the things that I find most satisfying
with code like this that I know that
that it is an actual right one it is
type safe type so you use in um class if
you can
but if you want to print it out there is
a way to make it printable because if
you try to print that there's no no
automatic conversion again so you
actually have to make figure out how you
want to print it and so it has this
stream operator to do that and then this
will write an e WS okay string literals
string literals are kind of cool I like
though I would probably like in my
experience you don't write a lot of
strings around in your code and the only
place that you write a lot of strings in
your code a hard-coded lots of strings
is generally in tests but in tests this
is kind of annoying and so this is a
very nice way of a like let's say that
you have an array of inputs that you're
going to go through you have an array of
outputs you want to go through okay
maybe this is a better way it's very
clean you just say spider-man and then
this lowercase s for all of them and
then you loop through them you can put
this in the loop but then it didn't fit
very well on the slide okay so we have
used to define literals and the one
thing here that you see that I didn't
mention actually is that we have a four
for each loop here so I told you do not
use loops but I special especially don't
want you to use loops with numbers in
them so this has no numbers it's not
counting anything it's just looping
through the collection you don't have to
worry about running off out of on off
the end okay
so used to define literals and this is a
kind of cool thing here you have an H
which is equal to 24 underscore hours
and then you have a D which is seven
underscore days and then you try to add
H 2 D and like I said before and like
normal integers don't have any semantics
but these things do so when you try to
add hours to days you get a compile time
error because 24 hours cannot be added
to seven days maybe you wanted
and you can make that but I can also
show you how this works so how you do
how you make a user-defined literal is
that you make a struct so these are two
strikes they have an unsigned long long
num and and then they have this explicit
constructor that sets them no it's not
very special and then you make this
quote operator which gives you the
suffix that you saw it's like 24
underscore hours so this is how you make
it and it will make an hours object or
and the other one will make a day
subject so if you wanted to to make make
it possible to add days to hours and you
can make functions that could do that
right but if not then it's not possible
and trying to do it will give you a
compile time error so this is a way of
giving semantics to numbers instead of
using raw numbers in your code because
having numbers is a vulnerability right
it's it's a way of getting vulnerable so
trying to reduce where you use in Sandin
sign-ins and all sorts of raw data types
that don't have any semantics and
instead try to use things that have
semantics these are my personal opinions
okay so you cite Steve for sizes I this
has been a little bit controversial for
some people but I'm coming to the
conclusion that I like it so this if
you're going to have something that has
like the number of elements in the
collection then the normal thing now is
to return a size T one of the things
that is unfortunate is it is platform
dependent size and and like 64 bits 32
bit dependent which I don't like but
it's pretty good okay so I'd really
rather you didn't trust your external
input and this is not so easy because
it's not necessarily that you realize
what your external input is or where
you're getting it in
and it's not necessary that you know
that you're not sanitizing it properly
so this is where your fuzzers come in
it's a very good way of checking that
you're handling your your external input
correctly from static analysis they have
this concept here that they call taint
so the idea is that the the external
input that comes in is considered to be
dirty
somehow and anything it touches anything
it's given to becomes dirty
so this taint will spread into your
program through your interfaces as long
as this thing is passed so the idea here
is to stop the taint as soon as possible
to to sanitize it maybe move it into
something else where you do limit
boundary checking if you're doing and
maybe changing it to a totally different
thing but doing it as soon as possible
when you get it in so this is trying to
stop the taint and you have many
different things like you have
command-line arguments that we saw
because it's easy and you fits on the
slide but you have like things like
protocols you have size fields and
headers and they can lie right it
doesn't have to be the right size if
someone can craft a file and give it to
you and lie about the size of the body
and make you allocate more or less or
coffee more or less because they can see
maybe in your code that okay but here
they're going to add a little bit to
this so if I make this number this big
then they're gonna wrap around but
they're gonna believe that it is this
big and they're gonna copy my entire
payload into their memory because this
is the whole idea of vulnerabilities is
trying to make the program do your work
how can I manipulate their input to make
them do what I want this this is related
to I really rather you didn't allocate
with new and this is also a little bit
controversial but I would actually say
I'd really rather you didn't use
pointers a lot and the reason for that
is that as C++ pointer or a C pointer
doesn't have any good semantics in my
opinion again because it could point to
an object of this type it could be no
and it could just point to random memory
you don't know what it points to when
someone gives you a pointer you don't
know it's like you can check it for no
yeah that's great okay now you checked
it for no now you know it's not no but
you still do not know that this thing
points to an object that has that a is
there to has not been deleted because
you have to understand that this is like
yet the the object might be deleted but
it might still be there in memory it's
surprisingly fun in C++ how you can
actually call methods on deleted objects
and get away with it for a while okay so
so I'd really rather you didn't use
pointers a lot and then I say a lot
because sometimes it is fitting but
really think about it because this is
not a good way to access memory in my
opinion I'd really rather you didn't
write clever code and the reason why I
said clever is because sometimes you
think like oh this is really elegant and
I did this thing above a bar but the
thing is the more clever it is the more
and when I say clever I mean generally
it adds complexity or it makes it
difficult to read so that people you
know had to be really smart to
understand what this thing does but the
more clever it is the harder it is to
find bugs the harder it is to fix bugs
or that easier it is to introduce bugs
because you write the code now and it's
like perfect but then somebody has to do
a little feature adding a feature here
and there and and all of your or all of
your assumptions are blown away and they
end up introducing vulnerabilities in
your code because they didn't understand
it that's not their fault it's not
nobody's fault
but try to make it so that you're
thinking about who's going to read your
code afterwards try to make it don't
write the most clever code you can well
somebody had this this quote that said
that
to to debug you have to be be smarter
than twice a smart or something than to
write code so if you write the cleverest
code you can you're not smart enough to
debug in something like that I don't
remember but basically just try to keep
it as simple as you can because this is
where vulnerabilities can creep in I'd
really rather you didn't use shared
pointer a lot now this is I think most
C++ programmers agree with me on this a
lot of new C++ programmers do this
because they come from managed memory
languages and they don't really know how
to manage memory um in C C++ way I would
rather that you try to figure out how
C++ programmers usually do this because
first of all C++ programmers won't like
you if you don't matter to memory well
because this is like one of the central
things for being a C++ programmer this
is like if you don't do this well you
just nobody will call you a C++
programmer we are extremely careful
about our memory we know we have like
this little piece it belongs to this
thing which he's here which is and who
has the lifetime in the lifetime is this
and it's ridiculous how much C++
programmers can tell you about every
single byte they allocate it is it is a
fascinating thing but with shared
pointer the idea here is that you have a
reference counted thing Nana might feel
like oh yeah but this is basically
garbage collection right it's like we
count that but we count down that at a
certain point it goes away and first of
all a sham pointers in our garbage
collection it suffers from all of the
the same problems that these kinds of
reference counting systems have you can
have a circular thing and then it just
stays in memory but also it it is proof
you have no idea what you're doing with
your memory and so as so a superstar's
programmer will see shared pointer all
over your code and they'll go like I
don't think this good is very good so
I'd really rather you didn't do
SharePoint or a lot because then you
have to deal with your memory you have
to
explicit with the remember and you know
who Alex it and who is responsible to
deallocate it I'd really rather you
didn't share state a lot I used to say
here I'd really rather you didn't use
threads a lot but I changed my mind
because you can use threads and
especially if you have some kind of
high-level API which is which is sort of
like jobs but having threads that that
manipulate shared state is asking for
trouble asking for for bugs that are
really really easy to trigger because
again like you saw these vulnerabilities
they're trying to manipulate your
program to do something bad and in this
case they often do manipulations where
they are trying to introduce race
conditions so that they can do something
and this is about manipulating your
program sharing state is basically
making the manipulations introducing a
lot of different ways that they can
manipulate your program so that is my
last of my really rather you didn't so
what should I remember from this
presentation because this long
presentation and you might don't
remember anything well I'd really rather
you didn't you see if you don't remember
anything else and do that learn some
modern C++ and stuff because it is a
beautiful language inside of C++ there
is an island of goodness and that is how
we like to program in C++ today so don't
write C in C++ thank you
so are they any questions yes how would
I approach not writing clever code and
code reviews I guess okay when I this is
says an analogy it's a nicer analogy
than the xkcd because when I wrote my
thesis I had two people reading my
thesis and they had it on paper and they
give it back to me on paper and if I had
a paragraph where they both corrected a
lot both in the same paragraph and it
was a long thesis so there's like whole
sections nobody touched but if they were
all like writing a lot on one
that was a bad paragraph I I didn't even
care about their Corrections I basically
just said okay throw away that paragraph
we're gonna write that whole paragraph
again so so if you see a lot of focus
being paid to very small chunks it's
it's it's a it's a smell you don't
really have to pay attention to the
comments really because if there's a lot
of that then they're not really useful
it's basically saying okay to take this
out how can we write this in an easier
way because it's clear that people got
stuck here trying to get it so does that
make sense
[Music]
I think that's I think yeah oh yeah yes
yes so if you are the reviewer if you're
the review or how would you how would
you try to communicate the fact that you
fall I felt it is clever clever clever
here is not a really nice word is it
okay maybe I should say clever because
it sounds good
no I I would say that that you found
because it's much easier to instead of
saying you did something wrong you could
say something about yourself instead so
you say I you know this section I found
it really hard to understand and maybe
you can simplify it a little bit or
something because I had trouble
understanding what it did so basically
then you know the person can be think
that you know yeah well he's not very
bright but okay I can dumb it down for
him you know but at least you know
offending anyone and you got your point
across right yeah yeah okay any more
questions okay well thank you
there's that you should put green in the
box of course and there's some as some
of you velde stickers and pens over
there so I'll grab something thank you